what's going on reject nation it's greg
alba here i'm john one of our reward
tiers on patreon if you qualify for it
is whatever video you request we must
definitely put up on youtube no matter
how old or how irrelevant or whatever
and andrew Terpening has requested
exactly that a film that I did see a
teaser for a long time ago I don't think
we put up a reaction on YouTube because
Andrew sent this to us and I was like
dude I'm pretty sure we did it and then
I was looking for him like oh I don't
see it anyway I don't think we ever put
it up on YouTube or it got blocked or
something yeah maybe this a good block
it's called monster trucks which I heard
was a terrible terrible film I remember
anything about her than like talking but
it might be fun to revisit the trailer
oh yeah
just for you mr. Tripp Smith trip hey
you'll see something crazy sweeping out
right now so do you never seen anything
like this
[Music]
unidentified creature we're looking for
something unusual something dangerous
holt
[Music]
I already use this poor guy never
catches where I go how did you explain
take a look you like siding in my truck
this thing is awesome it's smart it's an
engine for my truck in that right treat
[Music]
[Music]
aren't you curious family what do you
need
[Music]
to remonster trucks
[Music]
greaseless could she fit January release
oh man
that film I remember was we got to check
that actual movie out we should check
the actually got to review it ASAP today
I mean we haven't seen this movie so
just doesn't apply but one segment that
John and I want to start up as a segment
called trailers revisited where we would
look at trailers which is whatever
movies that you know made an impact
Nana Steel's who says it's caught yeah
yeah no Makin's yes say how accurately
the trailers represented the movies see
what anticipation it sparked asked that
rang true versus not what still looks
cool even though we know it's not cool I
remember my first saw this trailer I
thought it looked absolutely terrible
yeah and I was torn
I was very torn and now this looks this
is like this is a major major flop
wasn't it yeah this was a big deal this
was like cost like a hundred million
dollars in it like flawed badly hit I
think it was one of those it was like
based on somebody's nephews drawing or
something yeah oh yeah feels that way I
think someone lost a job over this oh
and run rightfully so and if I'm not
mistaken this was one of those things to
where they had to like go back and
redesign the monster so it's not too
scary and it got reshot a lot and stuff
and well I mean looking at the trailer
I'm thinking this concept could have
worked if they really committed it to
being kind of cheesy monster something
that Michael Dougherty would do you know
but more for kids like this this
reminded me of the AG 13 I think it
would have been fine
grandpa's pg-13 yeah I feel like he
could see this this falls to me on the
more PG side of the spectrum like if he
made a PG movie they would look kind of
like this cuz I feel like the appeal
here is to kid like it's so innocuous
and light-hearted it even the way that
they're all behaving during like chase
scenes they're all like am because this
well I'm like this could have been one
of those fun weird original movies aimed
at young people that could have been
like surprisingly charming or it
than what I heard it was well I had a
little layer of spook to it a little
layer of scary maybe paranormal yeah
something that has a sense of wonder
with a little bit of fear it's called
monster trucks yeah and the thing is it
looks like a live-action cartoon as
opposed to it looks having a feeling of
monster involved at all yeah they're
like if you add a little bit of a
monster vibe or at least made the
villain scary the guy from my hunter
Holtz whatever that would have been cool
I mean there are ways that feel like
this could have worked but yet again it
also just sounds really stupid at the
same I didn't see it and the same stroke
I can see how it really like the ideas
robbing like yours they could have made
it better so I got probably totally [ __ ]
movies like I like Lucas till I love
Jane levy and and yeah the guy still
gets no he's Lucas till right yeah I got
yeah he has like the MacGyver show the
realm man this guy can't catch it
he's a talented actor chase got that
x-men movie though yeah it's raised in
first class and he has a cameo in Days
of Future past he's got that one and a
half x-men you know he's got that extra
character that no one remembers the name
- yeah he's cool though I remember him
being cool what was his name Bioshock
that's a video game my camera I think
his character named Alex like its actual
main food I just want to call him
banshee but that's Caleb Landry Jones
that's the director of Ice Age I don't
know why I requested this Terp but I'm
glad you did because this this is this
has to go on our to do list of movies to
watch I think I love watching a terrible
movie sometimes it's just what I need
put on Independence Day resurgence you
know is like sometimes you just need a
terrible movie to have faith you can
make it in this business
good microfilm schools yeah I'd sit
there learn what could have gone right
and to see something like that Greenland
and put together it gives me faith that
oh if this was able to get produced
maybe something I come up with can get
produced if Finn Jones can play iron
fist maybe I can too hey when they
reboot Danny I ran because you know
that's gonna happen it's gonna happen I
got the curls already they can't go
without liquor no yeah he's getting too
old guys did you see monster trucks who
here actually saw monster trucks why
don't you leave your opinion below how
much did you pay for that ticket yeah
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell you can check out our
essentially our second channel patreon
patreon comm slash the real rejects
become a patreon eject today peeps do it
and Happy New Year Angie Tiffany and